Mirela Turulja calls it her dream job.
For 12 years, she's worked in a state-run
home for the aging in Sarajevo, and she loves
it ... even though there are far too few staff
to take care of the 400 residents.
Mirela regularly works over 11 hours a day.
She's highly qualified, but the job pays just
500 euros a month.
"You have to finish nursing school, and that's
not easy.
And if you want to land a spot to study there,
you have to have excellent grades in school.
Then the training program takes four years
to complete.
Five actually...because when you're through
with classes you still have a year-long internship
and then final exams."
Because the training program they go through
is so rigorous, nursing staff from Bosnia
are also sought after in other countries.
Mirela says some colleagues work in Germany.
But now a scandal has tarnished the country's
reputation for nursing excellence.
Investigative journalist Azra Omerovic discovered
that several schools in Bosnia have sold diplomas
to people with no training at all.
She uncovered the fraud by posing as an interested
client.
"I called him and asked if he could help me
out with retraining.
He said sure, and we met up the next day -- right
here, where we're sitting now.
He told me to bring 2,500 Bosnian marks and
my school-leaving certificate, and that then
he'd be able to organize everything.
It took exactly 17 days for me to get the
diploma after that first phone conversation.
And I never set foot in a school, never mind
taking an exam of some kind."
Omerović and her editorial department secretly
filmed her interactions with the fraudster,
and confronted him when he gave her the diploma.
The employee in the area of public health
refused to name any backers.
And so far, he hasn't lost his job.
News like that makes Mirela angry.
She knows better than anyone how even experienced
nurses can make a mistake -- with potentially
fatal consequences.
Untrained staff who've bought their diplomas
could cause tremendous harm.
"It's playing with people's lives!
This is a job with a huge amount of responsibility!
If you do something like that -- an unqualified
person taking responsibility for someone's
life -- I could never do that!
Why on earth would someone do something like
that?"
Azra Omerović and her colleagues discovered
the diploma she bought wasn't just a cheap
copy of a real one.
It included certificates and documentation
backing it up.
It says Omerović trained at a nursing school
for two years, and there were even records
of grades she supposedly got in courses.
A foreign employer would never have been able
to determine it wasn't authentic.
"I'm afraid the German authorities are going
hit the wall -- the wall of organized crime
in Bosnia-Herzegovina.
If the Germans want to verify the diplomas
or the schools that issue them...or the people
that come to Germany with them to work...then
they're going to have problems with the relevant
Bosnian authorities.
Why?
Because the Bosnian authorities are part of
the criminal system."
The scandal is a disaster for nursing schools
that play by the rules.
The reputation for good work they worked hard
to achieve is being ruined by corrupt competitors.
"This is pointless!
We study in this school for four long years
to take a diploma and hopefully find a job
in the field.
Then they come and get the same thing in two
weeks.
It just doesn't make sense!"
The police informed the state prosecutor's
office in Sarajevo about the case four months
ago.
So far, it hasn't reacted.
Politicians are demanding diplomas be examined
for authenticity, but not an investigation
into the schools that issued them illegally.
Mirela Turulja says she's never considered
taking a more lucrative position abroad.
But for other graduates of Bosnian nursing
schools who dream of a job in Western Europe,
the fraud has made landing one a much tougher
proposition.